we're gonna move now to the new warnings
about from two leading health agencies
about the corona virus pandemic the
World Health Organization says the
pandemic is accelerating inside the US
the CDC is also concerned sending teams
to four states to help address outbreaks
there and all major league baseball
spring camps are temporarily closed
after some athletes and staff tested
positive for Cova 19 Michael George
joins us with the latest from Belmont
Park where they will be racing horses
today Michael good morning Jeff good
morning today for the first time in
Belmont Stakes history the race will be
held without a single fan in those
stands officials say it's not just
necessary it's a sight we should get
used to seeing as the corona virus
reaches record highs in some states the
Belmont Stakes is known as the third leg
of the Triple Crown but with the
Kentucky Derby and Preakness postponed
until the fall this year the Belmont is
first out of the gate Belmont Park which
holds 90,000 fans will be empty we were
committed to running the Belmont Stakes
we were committed to running the Belmont
Stakes in the month of June incredibly
unusual but in some ways it's fitting
for 2020 it's a very different story in
Talladega Alabama where 5,000 spectators
will be on site to watch the Geico 500
race on Sunday it's the first time
NASCAR is allowing fans back in the
stands in two months but Major League
Baseball is dealing with a setback after
the Philadelphia Phillies announced five
players and three staff in its
Clearwater Florida complex have tested
positive for the corona virus according
to USA Today the league will temporarily
shut down all spring training facilities
in Florida and Arizona on Friday Florida
Governor Ron de Santos addressed the
growing outbreak in his state you're
starting to see more positives
regardless of the number of tests so
that's something that we're obviously
keeping an eye on Florida is one of a
number of states that are seeing
dramatic daily spikes in cases along
with Oklahoma Texas Arizona and
California in an interview with CBS News
radio dr. Anthony Fauci said that's
problematic clearly we have not
succeeded in getting the public
whole uniformly to respond in a way that
is a sound scientific public health and
medical situation and it's unfortunate
and it's frustrating but in a positive
development New York City which had been
the epicenter of the outbreak is set to
start phase two of its reopening on
Monday which includes outdoor dining
indoor retail and salons it's clear that
over the past three months we have done
the impossible in Governor Andrew
Cuomo's final daily press briefing Cuomo
said New York's infection rate is below
one percent he credits in New Yorkers
willingness to wear masks and the
decision to wait to reopen isn't that
what we really showed over the past 111
days that working together works that
the only way forward is if I protect you
and you protect me and following New
York's example California and Oregon are
now requiring masks be worn in public
Texas and Florida's governors say they
won't issue similar orders Michelle all
right Michael thank you